I am here with Danny Meyer and Randy
guru Dee and it's been a big day for
these guys the stock of course is up
already what at forty seven dollars guys
congratulations thank you and it's great
to see you here great to see you okay so
I know you're gonna use these proceeds
to expand what to 400 stores in the next
ten years so where exactly are these
stores gonna be we've talked about a
really good plan of about ten shacks a
year here in the United States that we
intend to own we're gonna deepen our
roots in our current markets throughout
the East Coast Chicago we just launched
in Las Vegas a few weeks ago and later
this year were launched in Austin Texas
so we are really excited about those ten
tracks this year and growing beyond as
the years come okay so how about
overseas overseas growth yeah overseas
we're excited but we have a unique thing
I mean about 27 of our 63 restaurants
are already international have a great
partner in Mohammed all shy and the
Middle East an incredible dynamic
business there we see a lot of
opportunity in the UK as well we just
have one Shack and we're building our
second so you know we have a unique
moment being New York based where the
world knows who Shake Shack is I'm going
to take our time choose great partners
and grow it the right way so Danny
you're all about quality right quality
food and I think one of the challenges
that people have said is going to be for
Shake Shack or for any restaurant that
wants to grow this fast is how do you
keep that quality and how do you keep
the quality ingredients how to keep the
quality food as you are expanding
exponentially like this I think I think
you're right and in addition to really
focusing on quality the thing we focus
most on is culture how does it feel to
work there how does it feel as a guest
when you dine there how does it feel for
your community when a Shake Shack opens
in your community and that's the
governor on our growth and you know I'm
so proud that every time we open a Shake
Shack the leaders of that Shake Shack
tend to be people who have already been
stars in one of our other shake Shack's
so when you go there you can rely upon
the quality of the food but also more
importantly the culture you'll feel it
you will actually feel this uplifting
human energy and that's the brand but
the mechanics of that I mean you know to
make a burger tastes the same as it is
here in
as it would taste in Tokyo or as it
would taste in Beijing how do you do
that how do you make sure that you do
that while at the same time keeping the
cost levels the same it's real work it
takes a lot of time and a lot of great
leadership we were unique in that even
at our young age we've already set up a
global supply chain we've already had
that opportunity we kind of were
thrusted into growing up faster than we
needed to we also came from the Union
Square Hospitality Group we didn't just
birth this on its own and it was birthed
with the 30 year history of New York's
favorite restaurants that gave us the
opportunity to get out in front and
concentrate on how we're gonna do things
without worrying about the blocking and
tackling early on and now we've gotten
really good at that but I'll tell you
one thing it's gonna be a hundred
percent about our team executing on this
plan and I wouldn't trade our team for
anybody anyone who comes out with an IPO
of course wants to see the the price pop
but you know I always you kind of want
to look at it and say you know it's
great to have the long lines it's great
that people love the burgers but do you
worry at all Danny that there might be
too much froth too quickly into a
business that still has yet to largely
be proven to a larger investor group
well this is our first experience having
public investors and we we know that
that's a huge responsibility and I think
the thing that we will continue to focus
on is what we always do which is cooking
one burger at a time one smile at a time
for people we're not great predictors of
what's gonna happen with the stock we're
honored that so many people obviously
have an interest in our future which is
a really bright and long future but
other than that the one thing that does
feel great to us is that so many of our
employees are among our shareholders and
we're gonna be working for them just as
much as we're gonna be workin for
anybody else on the street you know I
can't help but notice of course that
your IP owing on a week when McDonald's
their struggles have been very glaring
they had a CEO changed on Thomson
cepting stepping down and I'm curious
from from your point of view as you're
growing as you see how they've how
they've modeled their business how
they've tried to keep quality of food up
and they have struggled with that what
lessons do you take from McDonald's
I think what we see is really a seismic
shift in people's expectations of food
today you know people want no hormones
no antibiotics in their burgers right my
kids are gonna grow up in a generation
of people who isn't gonna see fast food
the way that I think it's been seen over
the last few decades and those people
generally want to go to a place like
shake check we've helped to find that
and we're gonna be out in front of that
as we go I think focusing on what we do
is is what we're gonna be doing for
decades to come and I think we're going
to capture that shift in behavior of
today's consumer if you were at
McDonald's if you were advising
McDonald's what would you advise them
yet I wouldn't have any advice because I
haven't eaten there for so long that I
don't even have any perspective on the
brand I I just want to echo what Brandi
said which is which is this we're
talking about burgers burgers have been
around for a lot of years it's not a
trend we didn't invent it we won't be
the the first or the last to do this so
what we're trying to do with burgers is
to say if you take something that
beloved and that's simple and just do a
couple tweaks the biggest one being how
did you source your beef how did you
hire your staff how did you hire the
kind of people whose greatest pleasure
in the world is making other people
happy caring for their communities
people are attracted to that and and one
of the things we're most excited about
we hear a lot about the the fast casual
world we really think that Shake Shack
is at the beginning of a whole new
category called fine casual our pedigree
our fine dining restaurants but we've
got a team of people led by this great
CEO Randy guru Dee who can take the
systems that fast-casual knows and apply
them to the the choices and priorities
that we've always made in fine dining